so hi everyone my name is Omar and today
I want to talk to you guys about a
project I've been working on along with
my colleague JC and a bunch of other
fine folks we want to talk about the
project called sidekick build which we
have here in our title built system
generator for seed Python see extensions
and that's not entirely clear what we're
talking about hopefully it'll be more
clear as we start talking and getting
into the details right so one question
that just in case you might have is
about whether see extensions really
matter I mean you could do a whole lot
with just Python code and we did some
stats looking at packages on Python
wheels looks like slides not fully
rendering oops oh right sorry right so
we looked at 360 of the most downloaded
packages just from what we saw in Python
wheels com we noted about 34 of them all
depend on platform specific packages so
you know the using this as maybe a proxy
metric for some of the most commonly
used python modules think you can say
probably around one out of every ten of
them are needing platform-specific
extension module so definitely these
sorts of things are important it's not
like this is a corner case use case
that's only serving a niche select of
selection of functionality it's
something that we need to focus on and
make sure that we do it really well and
not just do it well but make the whole
process easy both for package authors
and for users of those packages so this
is just a little word cloud we put
together of some of those big packages
that we found JSON being really popular
everyone likes JSON but you also see
we've got a lot of
the usual suspects we see numpy and
pillow matplotlib syfy a lot of the
status i pi stack is all there so
there's there's a lot that there's a lot
going on here that we want to be able to
support really well as far as the
packaging infrastructure goes so these
sorts of things are going to have
impacts one of the observations we make
here setting up a project with compiled
modules is tedious I think that's maybe
putting it a little charitably and these
these tend to to impact your everyday
work whether you're the guy who's just
writing the code or you're maintaining a
project or you're just the user who's
trying to pip install XYZ and you know
maybe the process doesn't just work
perfectly the first time you know
ideally we'd like to be able to improve
that situation so I want to present our
projects I can build which is a reliable
and easy way to package your compiled
Python projects I'll tell you a little
bit before we get too far into details
there I'll tell you a little bit about
some of the quick review like a little
history lesson on what's going on with
Python packaging get into some of the
motivation about why we were doing this
work and hopefully convince you all that
we have a need here that psychic build
will be we'd like to address with our
projects I could build then I'll hand it
over to my colleague Jay see who will
get into more of the details about so I
could build itself how it works and
maybe show you guys a few demos so we
had first disc details which you know
they put together for C Python it was
always from the get-go just meant to to
help to build C Python
and not really much else and as it turns
out tends to be great for that and not
much else just actually seeing here on
the dock page we can see that's
indicated it's a legacy legacy software
a lot of very common use cases that dis
utils don't really handle they never
really tried to handle and so we've had
a lot of other projects try to spring up
to try all try to approach addressing
some of this use cases that district
tails wasn't handling and so now we've
got set of tools which has been the
current de facto standard for a while
distutils to which i might put a
question mark next to that i don't even
know what's what's going on with that
it's supposed to be a fork yeah I see a
thumbs down yeah that's that's what I
was reading when I was checking up on
the mailing list and such that you know
they tank to that and a bunch of others
that are probably too many to name
individually but there was a lot going
on as far as folks all trying to address
what is what must clearly be a lack in
use case coverage here we looked at just
some trends about set of tools and
district tales and this again just
echoes the story that I'm talking about
about what was going on with the
packaging world we see distutils the
it's the big was the big thing when it
was the only thing that we had for seed
python and then as setuptools sorted
started to spring into prominence we see
interest in dist utils just fallen off
um but it's not all negative I don't
intend for this to really be a negative
message because really the important
thing I want us to take out of all this
is that we've had a lot of time that was
spent with a lot of folks working on
these sorts of problems and we've had a
chance to learn a lot from that work
that we've done and so even now we've
got a bunch of new standardization
efforts that are coming out of these
lessons learned just a three peps hear
that
we've highlighted I'll highlight
particular the wheel binary package
formats the basically the big packaging
format that we're going with now for
binary packages and then there's also
the addressing the issue with specifying
requirements in executable code which is
as its own problems so there's a pep 518
to try to address that and a lot more so
you can check out the all the list of
the peps if you really wanted to get
into the into the nitty-gritty of the
standardization and just real quick I'll
just touch on some of the terminology
that we'll be using throughout the talk
just to make sure that we're all on the
same page if we talk about source
tribution distributions we're talking
about really just plain source files no
binaries or binary artifacts that are
built from any sources provided these
are typically package tar balls that
provide some metadata and mostly source
files that our current tools like pip
will be able to use for installing from
the source and then from there or we can
use it to build from the source to
generate another distribution we call
built distributions which provide the
metadata plus source files I don't think
that's actually right oh I keep seeing a
different version of the slides on my
machine yeah it provides metadata
pre-built files so these are the
binaries and such the idea with these is
the only thing you need to do to install
them is just move the files and copy
files over the right places in the in
the target file system and in particular
when we say binary distributions we
refer to a specific sort of built
distributions that include
platform-specific compiled intentions so
build distributions that are not
universal that will be you know just for
Linux or particular version of Windows
and when we talk about wheels I think
probably most people hear no wheels it's
a built distribution format introduced
in pep 427 and basically the big
standard that we want to stick with
we've had eggs for a little while and I
think we're sticking with that wheels is
the N is the way forward and a lot of
what we want to do was I could build
make it really easy for you to build
your codes in a way that makes the wheel
generation process automatic we can
might talk about some Python
distributions and we make the
distinction between pure distributions
which are not specific to a cpu
architecture and don't have a bi you
know they're not pegged to a certain ABI
and then the non-pure version is the
basically the opposite of that so with
our current tools we observed that they
handle a lot of the common needs but
they leave a lot to be desired a lot of
them are sort of designed primarily with
the focus of handling the packaging
requirements and then to handle the the
compliation side of things they do like
their own system or their their own
hand-rolled system and it's you know
those kinds of systems aren't going to
work for quite as many use cases are
quite as well as a solution that say is
developed exclusively for the purpose of
handling the compilation of your codes
and the building of code so one of the
things we were thinking of is if we can
tap into what we currently have in the
Python ecosystem for handling the
packaging sided solution and then bring
to bear some of what we've learned about
handling the build systems and the
compilation sort of side of
oblem and so are our primary observation
is when you consider a number of
requirements that that we have to reckon
with like needing to be to be able to
reliably build native codes needing to
create extension modules for Python
scripts we want to be able to if we so
choose dynamically or statically linked
extension modules for use in embedded
applications if we wanted to say skip
the interpreter entirely in hand all the
compiling packaging and publishing you
know complications and details and when
when you're looking for something that
does that all these things and do it in
a way that's all integrated with the
current Python ecosystem including
first-class cross-platform support and
cross compilation capabilities you know
you have like all these requirements
that you sort of stack up together and
it's it's our observation that there's
not really anything out there that
handles all of these things in a really
well integrated way we've got a lot of
tools that are available if your
requirements aren't quite so restrictive
or you can you know you've got stuff
that does packaging really well then the
compiling extension modules maybe that's
fine if you're doing just regular
dynamic modules but now if you need
cross compilation or static linking
stuff then things get really tricky
really fast so the driving argument that
i want to make for the rest of the talk
and central sort of central thesis that
i want to submit to you all is the idea
that there is a clear need here for a
cross-platform building and packaging
solution that supports projects that use
compiled modules as well as the users of
those projects and so with that thought
I'll hand it over to JC to tell you
about our project thanks i'm out i'm
excited to be
I got my packaging ads I mean not really
but yeah and my boat sucks I mean I it's
great ok I'll solution is tacit build
what is cited in its a packaging
solution that bridge of a gap between
sameach c c++ and site and project and
the Python ecosystem and also you would
be able to be the fortran code what is
image what are the benefits it's open
source well maintained and supported
support cross-platform build with
support for cross compilation system
introspection capabilities support for
Native youth system Visual Studio any
version you name it ninja makefile
generation of your system and opening
your mind in eclipse in Xcode and a
strike for the development to meet your
development easier super fun native
build system and then obviously Titan
extension module support what what's the
current landscape to to build C C++
application we had configure auto tools
ought to make successful in the early
two thousand and then and then see make
started to come into the scene initially
created to to be able to build big
libraries like IDK and VT k imaging tool
kit and visualization tool kit in a
cross platform where and 15 years ago
when when we started nothing existed and
that's where Simic was created the
intent is ready to have a declarative
way of doing project I think now we are
mostly there and any we can see the
trend if that means anything on google
trend and and the yellow liner go down
the sea make one go up and is also wired
to go let screenshot
you know I mean and if you want to play
with it but that's Mulan chart you can
click on the button okay what is psychic
build it's a drop-in replacement for
setuptools you write your setup I know
set of tubes extension no build
extension required you've right you seem
excessive extension modules and then you
call Python set up by BD squeal or build
on any of the usual target or as this
eve Allah that's it know what psychic
bill is not it's not yet reinventing the
wheel it's not a new paradigm it
integrate with existing tools we are not
trying to to write this system
management and it's not a replacement or
cannot be conned out I pie it does not
manage packages it only makes building
them easier meaning it will integrate
with any of this python distribution or
system it's not magic I wish but no you
are still compiling extension modules
but only with much less guesswork ok the
LOL and if you have a yellow folder and
inside that folder you want to to to
compile a smaller c++ extension and what
do we need we need the setup dy the
usual the usual things and then the
other our packaging a mellow and then
you have the source and and in e dot py
ok what's the content of the of the
setup I pretty simple it's the same the
only things are going to have to add
that i forgot ear is over from
psychic bill import setup it means
instead of importing setup function from
setuptools you import it from psychic
bill oh yeah my screen doesn't show me
the same thing as you can see ya that's
why i was confused but yeah you have the
Front's i could be impulsive up here and
then how do you actually build that
small hello dot C XX you have a Simic
list simic this is a way of declaring
your your your compiled project you give
a name version you require some some
some dependency we require Python we
require any provide Python extension
module within psychic bill it means that
going to give you this small function
like Python extension module they're
going to take care of of building things
statically or shared depending on the on
how you want to reuse that project but
in the context of building a really
going to do a share library and then you
add an install rule and you install in
the ello package and and that's that's
all on that's all you need in that file
you put that file at the source of your
project then you invoke the setup that
py beast wheel and then you're going to
get a wheel okay and what can you do
like now if you have the source of your
simile is in a different folder or not
at the root if you want to install the
project like relocate the project if you
want to give an existing project you
want to graft it in a wheel you want to
pass some option like in if you have
your regular cyber space project and
then you're like a when I build it in a
wheel the context going to be a little
different it means you can pass option
we see make args and you can specify a
sorcerer and install there and then you
can also from the command line if you're
experimenting or building on unconscious
integration platform you can specify a
ce mec option and you can also pop back
down a build tool option like dash j8 if
you use mage and that's what the command
line will look like ok now we're going
to look at a free example a pure pure
pure like project then ello going to be
the one building the c++ extension and
then ello seitan and I gonna just open
my terminal and build a museum or is it
big enough not gonna make it bigger come
on guys ah and do I know to do that
preference Eddie does that work I don't
have like the usual dumb terminal yeah
awesome cool okay I mean the test wheel
it means you're going to go into PI data
demo you're going to go at the root
you're going to clean to make sure you
start from a clean plate okay and what
we have here we have LOL oh site on Ella
pure let's just go into Ella pure and
yeah it's tricky things that I don't see
okay yeah I am and I have the yellow set
up the py this one is pretty simple it
just doesn't beat any compile extension
it just do the from skb limp a set up
and just to show you that even if you
don't build extension it still work it
means setup biggest dash will and you're
gonna get a wheel and then we can go
install that wheel but I will install
the one with the c++ extension are going
to be more fun ok now let's go in the l
0 1 and in the hello we have same thing
as I described earlier I'll set up the
Pyr cmake and II i do set up the two
iBD's tuile and you're going to see a
bit more stuff here and if you go up we
see we detect the platform do we support
like is a compiler supported and then
you start to build the project and
configuring the project building the
project great we got our el Oso and then
install the project and then it's
copying files around to make sure things
are consistent and then is creating the
wheel let's let's install that will now
LS list okay I got the wheel now I go in
my pie des a pie in my test will
environments I make sure I don't have
any ello I guess if and install hello
yes I don't have anything and then pip
install and I go into list and I install
the wheel great with is installed I make
sure to go in a different folder to
import the right things and now
we're going to go in my test will folder
and I'm going to run the yellow script
we're going to test and I cielo you and
what's the content of a things it's just
a import ello dodge and Oscar ello which
was out share library as me Militello
you great and now let's let's uninstall
it and let's install the and when we
install we can see all the file and you
can confirm it and installing a special
library also yes and now let's build
site on one site on one is a little bit
more tricky as you will expect if you
ever see a top-level see make lists that
include oh one more thing yes at a time
one more thing here we include the site
on a package that provide us with all
the convenience function to to invoke
site and generate the source and etc and
now if you go in the yellow site and
folder we gonna add our pyx file and for
the people who are not familiar with
that hello pyx without citing a site on
declaration and then you have our Simic
list and if you have a outside and
target that's a function provided by us
a cycle module and i generate the source
in the softs viable then we add an a
library it's a module with the source
and then we declare it as a Python
extension module and that going to add
some depending on the context you're
gonna have some some flag specific to
the platform if you on mac on linux to
do we clinking and so on it take care of
all of that and then you install a
target in the indo a low site and folder
and to give the concoct some context to
set up you is also very simple name a
loss item and then the package
tightened that's pretty much now I'm
gonna build it beast I guess I can go in
the story yes and now I am building the
wheel and you have the veal artifact
ello cyclinder des oh that was a general
generated build using the souls that
were generated with seitan and now we
can go and install other wheel let's
make sure I don't have a deeper
installed ello it's not there people
install seitan it was that means i
remove it and now i do a pip install of
the wheel and like Elena other Wizards
hello side ton beast and the install the
wheel wheel is installed I run my test
hello underscore seitan yeah hello you
the best example ever hello seitan is
doing the same thing it's importing ello
cycle and calling the media ello you
great the this stove is like small
simple project now can we do more
complex project and this with few things
I was like let's let's candy create a
wheel of sameach because ultimately you
will want to to peep in salsa make which
is a dependency and you want to be able
moving for to install any version of
cmake in your virtual environment and
not just rely on what's installed on the
on the system and and created a small a
a small project which I need to find the
name yes yeah and what do we have here
we have our usual set usual not so usual
but set of the 2i and Nia what do we
have if you have a name of the project
we see some option and because by
default this option are not enabled or
disabled it means for our distribution
we want to explicitly disabled testing
enable openssl disabled curse install a
dependency with a project specific and
then what do we have a pact
names image it means we will do import
image and then there is the sorcerer
because in my small project he I don't
have a source of cmake the source going
to be grafted into that tree I download
them into source folder and then I have
to install the air which is see Meg data
it means i will install the Simic
project under the data folder of the
CMAC package and that's pretty much
description classifier use your things
now let's look in the under the sea make
in it file what do we have here we have
a pretty basic things we have adjusted
this like a constant which are the
relative path to data being a tad data
share to be able to invoke this image
ultimately we will add a rapper script
in the in the bin folder and I'm gonna
now try to kill the wheel let's make
sure it's nothing dist folder let's
delete and let's do the usual set up
biggest will and ok now let's say I
don't use make I want to use ninja
because it's installed on my machine if
do dash G ninja all you could do if you
pay attention area dodge dodge G ninja
we are you pass the option to see Meg
but for convenience EV be automatically
pass this one and I do that and it
doesn't work because I don't know if I
could be installed yeah it means i need
to deactivate and do a work on work on a
Simic patent distribution which is my
own diamont where I build the project
and now I do Virginian ja I am building
and it turned out that my bill tree was
already created it means you didn't see
anything happening but i will delete the
bill tree of the project and now I run
again and it's configuring the project
from scratch and these like all the
introspection I was talking you about
because we will see make whiskey making
that case but but all the introspection
that happen on on the system to check a
do I have all the things required
and in like two so gone you're going to
start building using ninja I'm gonna be
like a minute or less to to build and
yet here we can see it's building up 200
on 500 it's going pretty fast and then
and then and then and then yeah that's
gonna yeah any won't work now and the
next step going to be to set up the
wheel building on many many linux how
many linux so that you have enough
official wheel you can install on lenox
same thing for windows same thing for
match and and waiting that's finishing
i'm gonna go on the what's next what's
next for the project support by project
Amal which is a a declarative way of
specifying instead of you set up dot pal
you have your pie pie particular tumor
roughly it's a pipe 516 model
communication and example project
integrating to other project I promisor
and Tony to update the pipe i py any
build system to use it matplotlib we are
looking into that seem engine and few
other one and and that's going to be the
thank you vat the repository to to check
the source code and if you just look at
it and pretty much on time and then
you're going to do the import install of
the wheel we have the package v our
requirements are outdated we all did it
every day and then all verbal a passing
on the free platform code coverage
ninety percent if you have a something
like android test and okay i got the
wheel i got the wheel let's put the song
and then and then we have the wheel air
are going to install it lets me to
school here I gonna install it in that
random environment yeah um peep
installed
I'm tired um seem a Titan distribution
list and the wheel and I'm inserting the
wheel well it's done and then and then I
turn look at that import sim age and
then what do we have a i forgot with you
yeah just image okay the bin there and
then if you do import process you know
the as a subprocess and then you do a SB
check kool & C make door but fangs plus
dash dash first version and then you do
a shell equal true don't do that at at
Adam some good it's not safe oh it's
better to give the array and I yeah
thank you I told you isn't magic yeah
now we invoke see make it means we have
a will bf's image voila for any question
yeah whatever one question a five minute
but if there are any way to build
multiple configurations of binary
extension at once and if there any way
to add additional words to the wheel
name AZ plus m KL four numpy and if you
can do we've set up I've to modify the
name of your of your of your wheel we
will pass for the option they are not
doing anything on the on the wheel name
yet it means that's the default option
use we set up source you will be you
will ever to do it
yeah and to the first part of your
question the answer is yes we can mean
you can maintain multiple configurations
actually arbitrary number of
configurations in parallel it's just as
far as labeling the wheels that you
create from those it depends on whatever
we get upstream from the packaging from
the Python packaging you know those
software so that might be like a pep or
something if you want to extend that oh
yeah oh sorry I can I I'm good okay um
so I think the litmus test for me is
whether you can get numpy to switch over
to this and numpy do some crazy things
to dis two tails and so I'm actually
pretty curious because you're also yeah
sort of replacing distutils so yeah what
the how how does that interaction work
and what I like if you need to use none
pies dis utils and you also want to use
psychic build like what's what's the
story there another like a good use
driving you scare that one of my pet
project is to to to switch vampire bit
system inside I already did that for
Python for C Python this already system
and you can cross compile it to any
platform that was like the first step
learn a lot doing that and step 2 and
step free gonna be non pine side by
because I face this problem like every
day I need to be alone like more exotic
platform it's a pain and yeah that's it
envy yeah